I wish I had more of these dreams I had
one dream I woke up so happy it was so
real I remember being in the kitchen and
all of a sudden I smelled broccoli I
took out of the fridge it was just so
real and when I woke up I was happy my
friends would say things like we'd be
near movie theater and they would say I
smell popcorn and I actually had no idea
that what they were saying related to
something they were taking in through
their senses from the environment Bryan
the train to work in the morning
the trains pretty crowded so you're
really close to the person next to you
see some older woman her hair was inches
from my face it was touching my face and
I was just grateful that I couldn't
smell I went on believing for so many
years that I had a sense of smell that
had to learn how to use it it wasn't
till at least midway through elementary
school that I said okay this is a real
thing that I can't do my father can't
smell smell my father entomology
assumed that I would not have a sense of
smell my earliest memories are my mother
sitting down with me was scratching
sniffs and I always just remember
thinking okay everything just smells the
same as I was working in the kitchen
everything was about to smell it was the
smell of veal stock bubbling on the
stove it was the smell of butter melting
in the pan smell gave flavor to all of
the different ingredients I was working
with without a sense of smell eating for
me became like my world had faded from
color to black and white I understand
it's very common for people with out a
sense of smell to not be able to taste
but that's not the case with me I have a
very vivid sensitive list
I can taste I have a true case which is
bitter sweet salty sour but I don't
taste flavors so
you know between two bowls of ice cream
I'm not gonna be able to tell which is
vanilla which is chocolate if it's a
really intense thing right in my nose
like for example going to the dentist
and having nitrous oxide I feel like I
smell that it's like a really yummy
thing to eat like yummy chocolate ice
cream but it sort of fills up the whole
head so there was one time in Seattle
there was a rose and I concentrated very
very very hard and I got a faint whiff
of it and that was probably the only
time in my life that I've ever smelled
anything I went for a jog one morning in
August it was early in the morning it
was raining they were playing movies in
the park it was the summertime they were
supposed to play Wayne's World that
night got rained out I was on my way
home a few blocks from home and I was
hit by a car she was nighttime I had had
my lights everything on my bike guy
opened his car door without looking I
went flying I don't remember when I was
flipped up onto the windshield and
fractured the back of my skull or when I
was flipped out on to the ground
I remember waking up in the hospital
needles in my arms so what's going on
and they told me he got hit by a car and
went online started searching you know
lost his smell head injury this is such
a thing I didn't even know it existed my
life is totally different now there was
a smell always constantly around me it
smelled a little bit like a garden
without the flowers I just figured you
know based on the shape of my nose and
the direction of smell that it was
probably smelling my brain and and I
liked it because it was a smell I would
later learn that this was something
called a phantom smell and they're
incredibly common with people who lose
their sense of smell
you can tell each season with the smell
on the air and everything and I don't
get that anymore so I lost my sense of
smell and because of that I am very
thankful that I was able to find that I
had a olfactory girl of meningioma which
is a brain tumor around the olfactory
bulb and was able to get it removed and
taken care of the scent of my leg and my
children you can tell them apart from
any any other kid and it's really a
bonding thing and it's like I've had to
like you only touch her mooring hugger
more
[Music]
there are things that people just can't
describe to you I'd really love to know
what my wife smells like when my son
smells like I think he smells sweet and
you know like a kid I just I wish I knew
I wish I could smell and kids pass gas
that I know what other people are making
such a fuss about think it like sort of
things the inside of your nose there's
this new car smell that everyone talks
about and they can't describe it
my baby that's my baby their new babies
smell really nice barbecue I think your
ass people come into my room and they'll
say how that smells just like you in it
I don't really get that I've heard him
say he smells like it's gonna rain I
just don't I can't understand how it can
smell like the weather winter time was
was always a the fireplaces on my block
back home was always a good snow growing
up as a kid I know the summers gonna
come up and there's gonna be barbecues
that's something I'm gonna miss to just
good times I linked with certain smells
I realized that I was picking up a smell
then it clicked and I'm like oh my gosh
it's the exhaust and the gas fumes from
the bus it was like someone you know
cracked open the window and you know I
had that little bit of hope that I was
helping my mother to cook dinner because
I couldn't stay away from the kitchen
and I had a sprig of fresh rosemary the
herb and all of a sudden this
hit me out of the blue is one singular
smell and at first I didn't know what it
was because it was so strong and so
potent and felt like it completely took
over my brain
I forgot that smell to be that strong
even if I take a shower and I put cream
on perfume and I want to smell like a
woman it it's just missing and I do
isolate a lot more now because I feel
safer just being with myself people get
angry you should be really upset that
you can't smell you should work on this
and rehabilitate it but for me it's a
non-issue it's something that I've been
curious about and now he's kind of
wondering just because it is attached to
memories so much that I'm wondering what
I'm missing out on it's like let's say
on the bus something smells bad cuz some
kids had something bad and at lunch and
everybody's like gagging and I'm just
sitting back and so it makes me feel
kind of special it's been research done
10,000 flavors that I will never know
and that's you know 10,000 conversations
I'll never have there's this old guy at
work and he was a close talker and I
thought who's try to avoid him whenever
I could
he's the nice guy you know his breath
now it doesn't doesn't bother anyone
we're cool
smell is linked to some of the most
important parts of our lives it's linked
to our memories is linked to our child
it's linked to our past it says a lot
about what we eat
how we choose to eat where we like to go
what we like to put on our skin it
brings us closer to people it makes us
recognize people that we love it's
complicated and it's not completely
understood by the scientific community
but we do know that it begins with a
molecule and there are many different
stops and signals along the way
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
you
[Music]